technology has sort of killed the DJ
star or maybe technology has actually
created the DJ stock every DJ gig I've
ever done is coming from a computer
connected to a terabyte hard drive
before technology I would have to focus
on what are the 100 records that I'm
going to fit inside this bag and it
better work and sometimes I've shown up
to parties in which the theme was the
exact opposite of what I was leaded to
me you know so if you're showing up to
black it's high up here at the Four
Seasons you know the police by NWA
is not a good look now I can instantly
goes Rat Pack if I wanted to I could do
a jazz set they do a Samba set I do the
EDM set they do old-school hip-hop soul
I can give you whatever you want
instantly there have been times in which
maybe a DJ that's open for me was like
wow that was really incredible song you
play you know how did you where'd you
get that from
and I'm not selfish I will actually you
know all right you got 45 minutes give
me a hard drive and I'll give him that
part you know and he didn't earn it have
to go through the battle scars that I
went through but I feel like the new
version of that is each one teach one
like spread it around so that it lasts